[Music]
it's plasticky sticky shiny
often in a weird pattern or totally
bland
you've seen linoleum
it's probably in your high school
hallway
in your closest airport and hospital
or maybe it's in your grandma's kitchen
at the very least you can find it on
home renovation television there might
be something beautiful but there might
not but there's a good chance there's
not much
so
still holding on to that 70s vibe
this linoleum has to go
linoleum gets a bad rap
but it wasn't always that way
linoleum was once the stuff of dreams
an exciting beautiful innovation in
flooring technology
so
what happened
[Music]
one day in 1855 a delightfully mustache
inventor named frederick walton was
gazing upon a humble jar of oil paint
he noticed settled on top of the jar was
a thick stretchy layer of material
it was linseed oil the paint's main
ingredient that had oxidized and this
attracted my attention
i know all about this from his 1925
memoir it's very out of print but
luckily the new york public library has
a slightly decrepit copy
in it walton reflects in great detail on
his 90 odd year life including his quote
boyish activities i was living in
comparative luxury i say comparative
because
we had few friends but no dinner parties
dances etc impressions of the american
climate the summer weather was
delightful except for the extreme heat
and visits to a psychic he said he would
put his wife into a trance
but mostly he wrote about his work
walton fancied himself an inventor and
this odd substance inspired him he tried
using it as a varnish and a
waterproofing material but it never
dried properly but was always sticky
however i was not disheartened
eventually he tried combining the dried
bits of goop with cork dust sticky gum
pigment then rolled it all out into
sheets backed by cotton cloth
it worked
he created a new type of flooring
in rapid succession he filed a patent
named his invention linoleum a
combination of the latin words for oil
and flax
founded a company to manufacture it and
began a mad men level marketing blitz to
promote it
advertisements which ran nearly every
day in london's papers and were
plastered at every train station touted
its many advantages
linoleum was warm and noiseless which
gave it an advantage over wood or marble
and it was waterproof flexible and
durable which made it far superior to
earlier floor cloths
which were basically just thickly
painted pieces of fabric
they protected your floor sure but they
smelled weird they were cold underfoot
and they wore out pretty fast
linoleum was kind of a miracle flooring
it was durable easy to make supposedly
antibacterial and could be mixed and
remixed into any number of beautiful
patterns
within a few years it was an
international hit
walton even built an entire town on new
york staten island devoted to
manufacturing it called predictably
linoleumville
and much to walton chagrin competitors
popped up all over the world eventually
overtaking him in popularity
linoleum was considered luxurious the
modern refined choice
it was all over the titanic
in fact it still is even as the ship
wastes away a few thousand feet
underwater the linoleum looks pretty
good
over time linoleum just got better more
durable more vibrant cheaper
by the 50s linoleum or lino its jaunty
nickname
came in a massive array of patterns like
hundreds
faux marble faux wood checks squiggles
stars stripes florals these cute little
mondrian looking square things
who could resist these colorful patterns
the lady knows what she wants as it
became more popular it became more
accessible just cut it right off the
enormous roll and bring it home and as
countless ads mentioned install it
yourself
it was everywhere homes schools shops
the perfect fit for anywhere high
traffic because it was so resilient and
easy to clean
but all that ubiquity kind of backfired
linoleum started to be seen as tacky
cheap that durability backfired too
patterns that fell out of style stuck
around and started to look dated
companies that used to focus on linoleum
also pivoted to new options like vinyl
which was cheaper and didn't require wax
to stay shiny
linoleum did enjoy a second wind in
print making and as a break dancing
surface
but alongside wood paneling and those
weird glass blocks
it fell way out of fashion
until recently
because seemingly against all odds
linoleum is making a comeback
it's featured on instagram's favorite
table and in a variety of trendy cafes
hotels shops and homes from copenhagen
to new york
not to mention this exceptionally cool
estonian kindergarten
people are loving linoleum for all of
the same reasons they used to
but there's one benefit walton didn't
anticipate linoleum is also really
eco-friendly
it's still made with roughly the same
materials as walton's first version
almost entirely renewable resources
you can technically eat it
though you really shouldn't
so before you start thinking about
ripping up that old linoleum in your
bathroom
maybe give it a second thought
[Music]
if you wish to learn more about my
invention please explore pamela h
simpson's work her articles linoleum
handling crusta the democratic coverings
for floors and walls and comfortable
durable and decorative linoleum's rise
and fall from grace are both
exceptionally well researched and full
of interesting bits like a detailed
description of my other very important
invention lincrasta i hear that it is
still found today in a variety of famous
homes
both articles are linked below
thank you for watching